hi I'm John Hope Bryant founder chairman
and CEO of Operation Hope and young
global leader of the World Economic
Forum I'm here in beautiful Jordan where
I had the chance to be here two years
ago with Queen Rania doing dignity day
in local schools and Queen Rania when I
saw these young girls respond number
they opened up they became like flowers
and i was told that they would not talk
to me these young girls would not say a
word to me but when i when i courted
them respect and dignity they deserve
when I respected their intelligence and
assumed they had good ideas it took a
little bit but after about five minutes
that hand started going up and then once
one hand went up with half dozen hands
burn up and
they started engaging and involving it
in the conversation so the window was
cleaned rania the door was been riding
the window was the dignity that I
accorded them and then the opportunity
was really the brilliance of their for
their minds and the thoughts in our
ideas and what then while I was told
these young girls would not say a word
to me after an hour and a half I
couldn't shut him up and so when they
want to bring queen rania at the end of
the session and even a lot of this is
caught on video you go to clear on you
as a website and guess the search
dignity deja me Jordan I asked him what
gonna work couldn't shut you up what was
it was going on it said no one ever ever
asked us our opinion it was ever asked
is we believe they tell us what we are
supposed to believe and they don't seem
genuinely interested in what we have to
say you seem genuinely interested in
what we have to say and we see Queen
Rania we see these other women they saw
my wife who is an amazing woman Sheila
Kennedy brians or
incredible reputation and had a business
card Kabul is going to have a business
card and they said well if she can do
that then I can do that not only Queen
Rania but here is here is a another
woman that we can relate to and here's a
man that seems to accordance respect as
an equal so they that's an example I
think that this is a universal issue I
was with body whom CEO of a beautiful
company here in least the air max and
he's doing work in in a settlement area
here in Jordan we went there and he was
the only private sector later that's
gone in this area so now he's opening
the door in the window for young people
to become entrepreneurs I want to become
entrepreneurs the dream big dreams and
become dreamers with shovels in their
hand shovels a lot of ideas shovels of
ambition shovels of desire and to open
up their their horizon to become
entrepreneurs small business owners self
employment projects because there's not
enough jobs to go around in Jordan
northern Italy she need 100 man jobs to
fill it up well you have sixty percent
of the population and the 25 that's not
going to change anytime soon you've got
to improv inspire a generation
entrepreneurs and self-employment
projects and powered people you do that
by changing the role models and changing
with these kids see and so they see
things differently i'll end with this
this this is not a Middle East problem
I'm from from the United States in inner
cities the United States which look a
lot like the settlers you have young
people who want to be drug dealers
athletes and rap stars and now these
kids are dumb and they're not stupid
they're very smart they're modeling what
they see you need to give these kids
something different to see if you can
get the role model level with a five
percent but the tipping
glad the parks and role models all
communities stabilize the problem is the
most amazing in urban areas in the US
have three percent role model 3.7 role
models for address this is too thin so
they modeled what they see versus what
they could be we can change in the u.s.
change in Europe change in Latin America
we change it in Asia to change it here
and I'm very hopeful very positive i
love jordan love being here and
hopefully you love this presentation
probably you tolerate it to me for this